there was an advertisement for Trump
properties on a state department website
that got like huge red flag and I get
pulled Donald Trump suggested using
Trump Doral in Florida for what was it
the G7 I think and there was a huge
backlash even among conservatives saying
you can't do it and he's like but we're
going to give the government a cheap
right and they're like we don't care
Donald Trump used Trump properties for
Air Force personnel who were like flying
to Scotland and then said yeah but we we
gave it to him at cost and there was
still a big backlash even from
conservatives who are like dude you're
still maintaining your business by doing
this so Trump got reamed pretty hard for
that now Joe Biden Joe Biden's son was
flown on Air Force 2 to China for a
billion dollar private Equity deal where
his family was given a five million
forgivable interest-free loan and when
Tony bobolinski found out they took the
money we told them not to do it he came
out and blew the whistle and he and he
said the bidens are compromised or
you've got the Ukraine barisma deal
where Matt taibi a liberal formerly of
Rolling Stone reported there were at
least a dozen or more investigations for
criminal activity into barisma where Joe
Biden's son was working and Biden
personally flew out after their PR
Company reached at the state department
saying why are you investigating stop
this now Joe Biden goes out there and
says if you don't fire the prosecutor
you ain't getting a billion dollars
I can't I cannot I'm sorry I can't
that's those are facts I can't stand by
while this is this is our facts about
complete misinformation
uh first of all Hunter Biden did not
earn 1.5 I didn't say it was at 1.5 I
didn't say 1.5 billion I didn't say he
earned any money did you not just say I
said he was flown in Air Force two by
Joe Biden to negotiate private a billion
dollar private Equity deal in China yeah
now I read about that and that's
definitely not a good look for Hunter
Biden 100 why was why why was Joe Biden
using government property to fly his son
for private deals in China uh whether
they got a deal or not it was probably
corrupt it was probably corrupted I'd
say it was I think there's corruption
again there's corruption on both sides
here but if I'm forced to choose between
Donald what's the misinformation well
the the misinformation here I was
referring to the there's a lot of
misinformation about the 1.5 million but
I know you didn't bring that in 1.5
billion
um which that was only like a goal they
were trying to make 1.5 billion in
capital
um attempted murder and still a crime
and then you said that they uh got a
five million forgivable interest-free
loan I haven't that I actually haven't
heard about but Joe Biden did not get
that special prosecutor fire you're
wrong you're you're so wrong you are so
out of your depth bro yeah did you see
the video of him uh talking about it
it's my it's did you see it listen it's
my understanding that this prosecutor
was fired for doing a poor job you were
wrong did can we name the prosecutor I
don't know exactly Victor shulkin
play the video sure well we're not I
don't We're not gonna play the video of
Joe Biden saying but uh I'll break it
down for you because Matt taibi is not a
conservative
the UK
froze the assets of mikola's lachevsky
he's the guy who founded barisma so you
don't have any idea what you're talking
about right now zlachevski was under
criminal investigation when Joe Biden
intervened there were at least a dozen
investigations into him and this company
Hunter Biden was put on the board for
seemingly no reason probably to Garner
influence when asked about it Hunter
Biden was asked if you weren't Joe
Biden's son would you have gotten the
shot he says probably not so even it's
his acknowledgment that's why they
brought him on we also have the emails
where when he's when he's doing his
Chinese negotiations to talk about the
big guy and that was confirmed by Tony
bibleinski I digress Victor shoken was
the prosecutor who signed a sworn
affidavit in court in Ukraine that said
he was investigating active
investigations and Joe Biden intervened
and put pressure on him and he had a
meeting with the president after the
president was told we're not going to
get the billion dollars and he said to
him you're being fired and that was it
so when you have the PR Company and
these emails are publicly released you
should probably read them where they're
saying why are we being investigated the
vice president's son is on the board and
then what was like a couple months later
Joe Biden flies out there he gets the
prosecutor fired here's the best part if
you're saying the prosecutor was doing a
bad job my question is how come the new
prosecute who came in cleared barisma of
all wrong clear zachevsky of all
wrongdoing allowing him to return to
Ukraine after he was under criminal
investigation and it's only after Donald
Trump got in and started pressing things
he fled the Monaco so if you don't know
anybody you can't just come on say it's
misinformation because I've done so much
reporting on this it's more important
more about the more about whether Joe
Biden actually played a role in getting
the prosecutor fired oh okay let's play
a video I don't want to see the video I
want to actually see an article do you
want to hear Joe Biden say I got him
fired because he because they wanted a
billion dollars and I held it over their
head
you literally did say it do you think
it's odd that Hunter Biden was getting
paid tens of thousands of dollars in a
position that everyone knew he shouldn't
be in he never had any vegetarians yeah
the board position yeah um I thought
that he took an unpaid job with that no
he got paid tens of thousands of dollars
and yeah and here's the thing is is kind
of like what I've already been saying is
I recognize that there's corruption on
both sides it was to my understanding
that Joe Biden didn't play a role in
getting that prosecutor but if I'm wrong
let's play the video all right let's
let's listen to the video I said I'm not
gonna or when we're not going to give
you the billion dollars
they said you have no Authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you you're not
getting a billion dollars I said you're
not getting a billion I'm going to be
leaving here and I think it was what six
hours I looked I said I'm leaving in six
hours if the prosecutor is not fired
you're not getting the money oh son of a
[ __ ]
you got fired and they put in place
someone who was solid someone who was
solid who cleared lotchesky of all
wrongdoing and then after Trump got in
they reopened investigations and he fled
to Monaco so it sounds like based on the
fact that the pr firm for barisma was
reaching out to the state department
that Joe Biden admitted he used a
billion dollars in guaranteed loan
something he's not allowed to do that's
what they accuse Trump of doing he
doesn't be authority to only Congress
has the authority to do it Joe Biden
illegally
said you're not getting a billion
dollars unless the prosecutor gets fired
Matt taibi you know who Matt taibi is
yeah Rolling Stone liberal hates Trump
wrote an article he said how about how
crazy it was that if you actually did
any amount of basic journalism you found
a dozen or more active criminal
investigations in this company in fact I
don't know uh there probably is if I
could just really quickly like I will
100 concede again that yes there is
corruption on both sides I hadn't seen
that video before so I will be 100
willing to look more into that yeah
that's the video that I was asking
specifically yeah I'm glad that you
played that for me because I mean I'm
always open to learning new information
and some but also come on I've been
wrong about plenty of other things
before too I'm not afraid to acknowledge
it yeah this is in the news also today
as the Department of Justice just
announced that they're investigating
Hunter Biden specifically with his
barisma ties and that's today that's
today and there's also let's find out
and there's also new emails showing that
there's close to four hundred thousand
dollars that were unreported income from
barisma when it comes to Hunter Biden
yes yes and this is important to to you
know understand here on the backdrop of
the Attorney General resigning today
since of course William Barr actually
hid a lot of this information before
this election and also made sure that
the subpoenas surrounding this
particular investigation weren't
released after the election now we're
finding out some of these subpoenas and
this could be one of the reasons why
William Barr the attorney general who
said he saw EPS the Epstein tapes that
were supposedly deleted resigned today
sorry that's another side topic that I
just borrowed but this is this is
important news because this broke today
and they're specifically looking at
barisma so this could this could blow up
in everyone's face very soon let's pull
the story real quick it literally goes
right back it goes right back to what we
were saying about the Dominion voting
thing like I've heard different
information than what I was just told
now but I would be more than happy to
see an investigation into this I don
don't want our politicians to be corrupt
Unfortunately they both are I mean even
like um uh Jared Kushner like uh I I
think it was a um I was in Saudi Arabia
yes he negotiated better weapons deals
for Saudia with what I'm talking about
I'm talking about
um another uh radical Islamic country I
can't remember uh no it was Qatar
um and they said that Jared Kushner
allegedly they said that Jared Kushner
was in his pocket so I think that
there's a lot of corruption on both
sides and I think that if anything like
I didn't vote for Biden because I liked
him okay not at all I don't I don't like
Biden but I was kind of stuck between
Biden or Trump and I felt like Biden in
this instance was a little bit of a
better option especially as
just as a dad there were a lot of things
I was seeing with what Trump was saying
that I just couldn't align with I mean I
know we talked about the flag burning
thing but even Trump's like uh 1776
commission
um with like trying to explicitly teach
children a a biased pro-american
Viewpoint like my daughter's almost too
when I don't want to think about it but
I know she's going off to school soon
right I don't want her going and being
taught like a brainwashed like the 1619
project like they're teaching right now
homeschooler well hold on hold on is the
six and this is something I want to know
is the 1619 project being taught in
schools yes is it a widespread is it a
curriculum it is really because that is
not what I saw when I read that when I
looked when I hear the wind blowing yes
that was crazy was that outside yeah
what what's going on tonight dark winter
wow the dark winter is coming thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live don't
forget to subscribe hit the like button
hit the notification Bell and we are
also available on all podcast platforms
for free if you want to listen to us
there thanks for hanging out and we will
see you all next time